thanos and death are completely linked
but the question of whether the mad
Titan might actually meet his demise and
Avengers endgame isn't as clear as it
may seem there are plenty of reasons we
could see his nihilistic life come to an
end in endgame but there are also some
good arguments that we probably won't
the comics version of the snap that
wipes out half of all life doesn't
happen at the end of 1991 s Infinity
Gauntlet or even close to it it actually
happens about halfway through the first
issue that's partially because the story
so much of the movie infinity war covers
with danos acquiring the infinity gems
occurs in the prequel comic Danos quest
it's also not the end of the story after
a massive battle in space that ends with
danos defeating most of the remaining
assembled superheroes from earth he has
to contend with the Marvel Universe's
cosmic heavy-hitters eventually he loses
possession of the gauntlets and it
becomes something of a hyper powerful
football nebula is the first to recover
it's Thanos has to join forces with the
revived Super Heroes to get it away from
her then Adam warlock takes possession
of it and he blasts Thanos into space
with mad Titan seemingly explodes what
really happens is Stannis is sent sixty
days into the future where he's living
on an unnamed planet and suffering from
a fuzzy memory he remembers his failures
though and he promises warlock that he
will lead a quiet life as a farmer
infinity war doesn't perfectly mirror
Infinity Gauntlet story but it hits
enough similar beats that endgame could
recreate its ending
according to Marvel wanna Thanos his
powers is immortality but he does die
one sword of death well before Infinity
Gauntlet even starts
Marvel two and one annual number two
from 1977 is one long fight between
Thanos and a whole host of Marvel
superheroes and it ends with Adam
warlock using the power of the soul gem
to turn Thanos stone that story
describes Thanos as trapped within the
petrified form of his own corruption but
13 years later when death revives him
and Silver Surfer number 34 cosmic
nihilist is described as having been
full on debt the Marvel Comics
embodiment of death can't have that
though because she needs Thanos to do
her bidding
it's not until 2018 s Thanos number 18
the death finally decides to let the mad
Titan rest determined to prove his worth
to death and
Bannos transports his younger self to
the end of time for one big final
showdown hoping to die in the process
the old Thanos loses the fight but his
younger self refuses to end his life
it's only after the younger Thanos goes
back in time the death declares his
victory and allows the old battles to be
erased from existence comic stories keep
going on and on forever and creators
often want to keep characters around for
future tales movies have far more
definitive endings and its more common
for characters to die permanently Plus
superhero comics fit within their own
particular genre while superhero movies
tend to follow a more standard action
movie templates ask any film fan with
the defining action movie of the last
few decades is and they'll probably say
it's the 1988 classic die hard which
ends with would-be terrorist hans gruber
falling to his death it's no surprise
then that the Joker dies at the end of
1989 s Batman and not only does he die
dies in exactly the same way as Hans
Gruber that movie kicked off a trend in
which the main villains died in most of
the subsequent Batman films The
Rocketeer x-men 2 the first two blade
movies spider-man and spider-man 2 pulk
Man of Steel deadpool logan police goes
on
it stands to reason then that Thanos
could share the same fate of all those
films bad guys particularly since
endgame is clearly aiming for a grittier
tone than some other MCU fare some of
the earliest MCU villains absolutely bit
the big one Iron Man's Obadiah Stane and
Iron Man twos even Vanko both died
Malekith the dark elf didn't live to
make cookies another day after Thor the
dark world and thousands of members of
the alien race of the Chitauri were
nuked and Avengers Ultron also seems to
be pretty dead at least as dead as an
evil AI can be but more recent entries
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe have
made conscious efforts to avoid villain
deaths in spider-man homecoming Peter
Parker goes out of his way to save the
vulture from a man to death in the
aftermath of a plane crash and Captain
Marvel Carol Danvers chooses to send
young raagh back to the Kree with a
message not to mess with earth rather
than take a revenge of course there are
exceptions to that rule to hell it
doesn't make it out of Thor Ragnarok
alive for example and kill mugger
chooses to die rather than go to jail
and black panther yet it's clear
villains at least don't have to die in
MCU movies in some very real ways the
stories of MCU movies are still driven
by the realities of the movie industry
including actors contracts in the
lead-up to endgame rumors have swirled
about the fates of Chris Evans Captain
America and Robert Downey jr. Iron Man
among others because the contracts are
seemingly coming to an end on the other
side of things Josh Brolin the actor who
plays Thanos may still have a few movies
left on his contract after ending Screen
Rant categorizes him as staying on as
part of the MCU for a bit longer noting
that he signed a multi picture contract
with Marvel Studios in the game is
technically Berlin's fourth MCU
appearance after cameos and guardians of
the galaxy and Avengers age of Ultron
and his star turn in the Infinity war
was his contract for more movies than
that Marvel hasn't revealed the details
in an interview on Conan Brolin did
indicate he's in for the long haul
they're gonna tell me what I'm doing
I'll say yes sir and I'll leave and I
get to play Thanos for like a few years
rumors are often like dust in the wind
but
we'd say this one has maybe a 50/50 shot
according to total film word is swirling
that Brolin Stannis will be appearing in
some capacity in the MCU phase fourth
film internals and it makes sense
thanassis comic book brother starfox is
an eternal a member of an ancient and
powerful band of early humans who left
earth and settled in space technically
Thanos is one too like starfox he has
one of the Eternals who lived on
Saturn's moon Titan naturally there's a
catch if he turtles is an origin story
similar to what happens in the comics
then it will take place thousands of
years before the current MCU which means
there would be no issue with Thanos
appearing even if he dies an end game
unless of course there's also a
modern-day component to eternals like
when the story flashed forward at the
end of Captain America the First Avenger
the MCU probably won't be rid of fan o's
whether he dies or not there's always
the potential of him showing up in a
flashback or a prequel like eternals may
turn out to be the Red Skull returned an
infinity war some 75 years after his
apparent death and Captain America the
First Avenger instead of killing him
the tesseract transports him to the
planet for Mir where he becomes a sort
of cursed guardian of the soul stone
Arnim Zola much like his comics
counterpart kept his consciousness alive
in a computer and Loki has died how many
times now sorry about this thing with
the tesseract I just couldn't help
myself
endgame is a movie in which fans have an
expectation that dozens of characters
will come back to life after blinking
out of existence in infinity war the MCU
is officially enough of a comic book
world that death can be little more than
a stumbling block rather than a hard
ending if Thanos does die in endgame
will it even matter maybe the more
poetic and fitting end for a genocidal
creep like Thanos isn't his own death
which he doesn't seem to fear but to see
his work undone then have to live with
his failure just like an Infinity
Gauntlet check out one of her newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Avengers endgame are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]